[Musique]
les essentielles du sénat
réforme éducative l'école a encore des
progrès à faire
à l'issue d'un quinquennat qui n'a pas
été avare en réformes dans le domaine
éducatif
seulement 4% des professeurs des écoles
considèrent que leur métier est valorisé
par la société est moins d'un français
sur deux estime que l'institution
scolaire est efficace dans la
transmission des savoirs fondamentaux
pour éclairer cet échec la commission de
la culture et de l'éducation du sénat a
passé au crible les mesures phares
le 23 février 2022 annick billon max
brisson et marie pierre monnier
rapporteurs ont présenté leur bilan des
mesures éducatives prises pendant le
quinquennat
la mise en oeuvre de ces réformes donne
l'impression d'une politique publique
menée dans la précipitation
résultat un sentiment de générations
d'élèves cobaye est une déception pour
le personnel enseignant
si les sénateurs salue le dédoublement
des classes de grande section au ce1 il
déplore que des mesures d'accompagnement
scolaire ne soit pas prise pour les
classes du ce2 au cm2
il approuve la hausse de 33% du
recrutement des accompagnants d'élèves
en situation de handicap tout en
soulignant la nécessité de renforcer la
formation de ses accompagnants
ils sont favorable à l'abaissement de
l'âge d'instruction obligatoire mais
regrette que cette mesure ne se soit pas
traduite par une politique
d'accompagnement des enseignants et des
personnels
en outre la réforme d'orientation des
lycéens qui n'a fait l'objet que de
débat limité au parlement reste
inachevée
85% des professeurs principaux et 65%
des proviseurs n'ont reçu aucune
formation spécifique pour exercer leurs
missions d'orientation
enfin les rapporteurs constatent qu'en
dépit de la réforme des instituts
nationaux supérieurs du professorat et
de l'éducation la profession reste plus
attractive
sur la base de ce bilan la commission a
adopté les 36 propositions des
rapporteurs
il préconise notamment des efforts
massifs en matière de formation initiale
et continue ainsi que l'accélération des
rendez-vous de carrière des enseignants
afin d'améliorer leur rémunération
face aux réformes du lycée il recommande
principalement un meilleur
accompagnement des lycéens dans leur
choix d'orientation la mise en place
d'une offre étendue d'options et de
spécialités sur l'ensemble des lycées du
territoire national ainsi que la
mobilisation des filières du supérieur
pour en savoir plus consultez la
synthèse du rapport
[Musique]